first at purewow reports legendary
singer and theme park owner Dolly Parton
admitted that she doesn't ride the
roller coasters at Dollywood because she
doesn't want to mess up her wigs okay
Dolly has famously said that she wears
wigs so that she can have a big hair day
not a bad hair day you have brilliant
and you know Ross I don't know like I
feel like a wig could withstand a roller
coaster if you had the right pins on I
don't know what do you think well I get
it I mean it must be hard if you have a
wig on with all that wind in your face
well hold on let's just what if we just
right now what if I just were to
do something like this and then
basically I'm Dolly and then but what
have we okay scientific study
ing
all right oh whoa okay
[Applause]